We start in a stadium built for the 2010 World Cup,...
...but there's no action on the field, no crowd cheering in the stands,...
...just a terrified scream from 300 feet above.
It's a 262-foot free fall called the Big Rush,...
...and what follows the drop, that 721-foot arc,...
...makes it the tallest swing on earth.
You're completely free falling; you relinquish all control.
Want to take your game to new heights?
Get your butt to South Africa to the coastal city of Durban...
...and the Moses Mabhida Stadium.
The journey up starts with a ride to the top of the dome,...
...but you're still 352 steps from the Big Rush...
...and that climb is so steep, so dizzy, they make you wear a safety line...
...like you're scaling a mountain,...
...but the freakiest part is the jump platform.
Less than four feet wide, it's got just one railing...
...and the winds up here hit 30 miles an hour.